جددت قوات النظام السوري وحزب الله
اللبناني هجومه على منطقه وادي برده بريف
دمشق ياتي الهجوم في وقت اجرى فيه علي
مملوك رئيس مكتب الامن الوطني السوري
ووزير الخارجيه وليد المعلم محادثات في
طهران مع مسؤولين ايرانيين تناولت
المستجدات الميدانيه في سوريا بعد اتفاق
وقف اطلاق
النار
[موسيقى]
انا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما اهداف زياره المعلم ومملوك
لطهران في اليوم الثاني لسريان اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار في سوريا وهل من تباينات في
تفسير هذا الاتفاق والتعامل معه بين
الجانب الايراني السوري والضامن
[موسيقى]
الروسي محادثات وليد المعلم وعلي مملوك في
طهران ترافقت مع اجواء ملبده بالقلق من
انتهاك اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في سوريا
فالات اك تحدثوا عن محاولات لتقويض
الاتفاق تمارسها دول لم يسموها فيما طالب
متحدث باسم الحرس الثوري الايراني تركيا
بما دعاه احترام الشعب السوري وحكومته
الشرعيه اذا ارادت ان يكون لها دور مهم في
هذه المرحله وقد استمع الوفد السوري خلال
محادثاته مع الرئيس الايراني حسن الروحاني
ووزير خارجيه محمد جواد ضري وعلي شمخاني
امين مجلس الامن القومي الايراني استمع
الى تاكيدات بان الضامن لوقف اطلاق النار
هو الحفاظ على قوه النظام في سوريا
ومراقبه تحركات الجماعات المسلحه تقرير
مريم
ابيش مشاورات طهران هل تمهد لمفاوضات
استانا ام تعرقلها قبل ان تبدا في اليوم
الثاني من دخول وقف اطلاق النار الشامل
حيز التنفيذ بضمانات تركيه روسيه اختار
وزير الخارجيه السوري وليد المعلم مرفوقا
برئيس مكتب الامن الوطني علي مملوك ان
تكون الوجهه الاولى ايران في جدول اعمال
الزياره التي لن تدوم وفق ما اعلن رسميا
اكثر من يوم واحد لقاءات مع وزير الخارجيه
جواد ظريف وامين مجلس الامن القومي
الايراني علي شمخاني شمخاني هو ايضا منسق
الاجراءات السياسيه والعسكريه والامنيه
بين طهران ودمشق الى اي مدى ستقترب وجهات
النظر في اجتماعات طهران من الرؤيه
الروسيه لمستقبل سوريا والساعي الى انجاح
الهدنه قال شمخاني ان اي حوار سياسي يهدف
الى اضعاف سلطه الحكومه على كل الاراضي
السوريه هو حوار محكوم بالفشل مضيفا ان
الضامن لوقف اطلاق النار والتزام المسلحين
به هو الحفاظ على قوه النظام في سوريا
ومراقبته لتحركات وانشطه الجماعات المسلحه
مؤشر اخر وهذه المره من المتحدث باسم
الحرس الثوري الايراني يعزز الشكوك في مدى
رغبه طهران في صمود هذه الهدنه اذ قال من
المحتمل استمرار العمليات العسكريه لمحور
المقاومه في اي منطقه من سوريا مقاومه من
وما هي حدود هذا المحور هل فعلا ايران
وميليشياتها راضيه عن الهدنه 100% علما
انها شاركت في الاجتماع الثلاثي بموسكو
والذي مهد لاتفاق انقره ليس من لا شيء على
ما يبدو جاء اتهام وزير الدفاع التركي
بلدانا لم يسميها بممارسه اعمال من خلف
الستار لتقويض الاتفاق بالرغم من تغريده
وزير الخارجيه الايراني جواد ظريف واصفا
الاتفاق بالانجاز الكبير قال اكثر من مصدر
ان ايران ليس من مصلحتها الان نجاح
الاتفاق ولا المفاوضات المرتقبه في
العاصمه الكازاخيه المفارقه انها ستكون
حاضره في المفاوضات لكنها ربما وفق محللين
تفضل جدول اعمال لا توافق تماما مع ذلك
الذي يناسب روسيا هما فعلا يدعمان نظام
الاسد ولكن بدوافع واجنده مختلفه بدليل ان
نظام دمشق وميليشيا حزب الله وبعض
الميليشيات الايرانيه خرقوا وقف اطلاق
النار بعد اقل من ساعه من سريانه اشتباكات
منطقه وادي برد الاستراتيجيه بريف دمشق في
صداره قائمه الجبهات التي لا تعرف اي هدنه
اذ يسعى النظام المدعوم من ميليشيات
طائفيه الى تامين دمشق و محيطها بشكل
النهائي وكل المناطق الواقعه على الحدود
اللبنانيه لن يكون يسيرا على موسكو وانقره
منع انهيار الهدنه في حال استمرار
المواجهات في مناطق لا دليل على وجود
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه او جبهه فتح الشام
فيها هل بدا يصدق وصف محلل سياسي في صحيفه
الجاردين البريطانيه بعد سقوط حلب عندما
قال روسيا وايران تتخاصم اليوم مثل اللصوص
على اقتسام من
هبوه نرحب بضيوفنا الثلاثه في هذه الحلقه
من بيروت توفيق شمان الكاتب الصحفي من
اسطنبول سعيد الحاج الباحث في الشان
التركي ومن باريس محمد قواص الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي نبدا من اسطنبول وسعيد
الحاج برايك ما الذي ذهب المعلم ومملوك
يبحثان عنه في طهران بشكل
خاص مساء الخير استاذ محمد لك ضيوف
الاكارم والمشاهدين بطبيعه الحال الان
الاتفاق التركي الروسي الذي افضى الى وقف
اطلاق النار وما سبقه تحديدا اتفاق اجلاء
المدنيين والعسكريين من حلب ادى الى نوع
من المتغيرات النسبيه في التحالفات في
الازمه السوريه بمعنى لم يعد الان الحديث
عن محور روسي ايراني سوري في مقابل محور
تركي مع المعارضه مع الغرب دقيقا بالمعنى
الكامل نسبيا اصبحت تركي اقرب لروسيا
باعتبارهما ضمتين لهذا الاتفاق بينما
ايران باتت اقرب للنظام السوري نحن الان
اعتقد تمام سيناريو شبيه بما فعلته ايران
وميليشياتها فيما بعد اتفاق اجلاء
المدنيين والعسكريين من حلب استبعدت في
البدء من هذا الاتفاق ثم لاحقا عبر الضغط
الميداني من خلال الميليشيات فرضت نفسها
على القمه الثلاثيه في موسكو اعتقد الان
انه كلما تقدمت العمليه الميدانيه
والسياسيه في سوريا فتحققت بعض الاهداف
العريضه والعناوين الكبيره بالنسبه ل
النظام السوري وحلفائه كلما بانت بعض
التناقضات الخفيه بين افراد هذا المحور
تحديدا نتحدث عن روسيا وايران انا اعتقد
ان ايران ليست عيده تماما بهذا الاتفاق
وبالتالي ثمت حاله من التنافس بينها وبين
روسيا على قرار النظام السوري روسيا تفرض
نفسها من خلال هذا الاتفاق على انها ضامنه
وانها صاحبه القرار الاول والاخير للنظام
السوري حتى انها بلورت هذا الاتفاق مع
انقره ثم بعد ذلك عرض على النظام
والمعارضه بهذه المعادله ايران لا تريد ان
تفقد الدور تماما تريد ان تكون ضمن صيغه
ثلاثيه ضمانه للاتفاق ضمنيا وان لم يكن
معللا وتريد ايضا ان تفقد حاله التنافس مع
روسيا على قرار النظام والاهم من ذلك كله
هوما يهم انقره لا تريد ان تخسر خطوات في
حاله التنافس الاقليمي مع تركيا صحيح ان
تركيا وايران ليست متواجهين بشكل مباشر
جدا على الارض ميدانيا لكن حاله التضارب
في المصالح وحاله التنافس الاقليمي واضحه
بشكل واضح جدا وبالتالي هنا يبدو يبدو ان
انقرى تحاول قدر الامكان الضغط على ايران
من خلال روسيا بينما ايران من خلال
ميليشياتها تحاول ان تضغط على الموقف
الميداني لتحصل مكاسب اكثر يبد
ان اكثر السياب حقق نقاط بعد بعد عندك اذا
كانت روسيا هي الضامن للنظام ومن معه سيد
توفيق شومان وتركيا هي الضامن للمعارضه في
هذه
الحاله ما
ماذا يتوقعه النظام السوري من طهران وهو
وهي حليف قوي
لله يعني انا اعتقد بان هناك تفاهما
اساسيا يعني بين دمشق وبين طهران حول تنس
سيق المواقف لذلك جاءت زياره وزير
الخارجيه السوريه وليد المعلم واللواء علي
مملوك الى طهران في هذا في هذا السياق
يعني نحن امام ثلاث اجتماعات هذه السنه
بين وزيري الخارجيه السوريه والايرانيه
بدون شك السيد علي مملوك وهنا ربما قد
يكون بيت القصيد السياسي كما يقال واهميه
زيارته واجتماعه مع الجنرال علي شمخاني
باعتباره منسق العلاقات السوريه المنسق
العلاقات السياسيه والميدانيه والعسكريه
السوريه الايرانيه
الروسيه طبعا اللواء علي مملوك يطلع بدور
مهم كان في فتره لاحقه هذا العام في في
دمشق في القاهره طبعا ماكس مده في في واشن
في في موسكو وكانت له جولتان ايضا الى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض اركز هنا على
مساله في غايه الاهميه انا اعتقد بان
المواقف السوريه والمواقف الايرانيه في
هذه المرحله تبدو اقرب من اي وقت سابق
لسببين رئيسيين ان القرار الميدان العسكري
يعني منذ منذ الدخول الا المباشر في
الازمه السوريه وتحديدا ميدانيا انا اعتقد
بانه كان هذا وفق تنسيق سوري وا وايراني
بصوره اساسيه بعد ذلك جاء حلفاء ايران
وتحديدا اقتد حزب الله اللبناني في هذه
العمليه لذلك اظن بانه التباين الذي يمكن
الحديث عنه تباين لا يرقى لغايه الان الى
تفاصيل طالما ان اتفاق او اجتماع الاستانه
وقبله الاتفاق الذي جرى في موسكو غير ظاهر
لغايه الان لا توجد تفاصيل عنه وبالتالي
لا اظن بان الحلفاء يمكن ان يختلفوا في
هذه اللحظه قبل التوصل الى اتفاقيات معينه
ولكن اود ان اشير الى مساله مهمه قبل ان
اقتصر وربما ايضا يعني تنتقل الى باريس
بان هناك تباين و تباين بحسب تقديري واضح
في العلاقه في في العلاقه او في الحل
السياسي الذي تريده طهران بسوريا طهران هي
مع بقاء الرئيس بشار الاسد وبالتالي عدم
المساومه على الرئاسه باعتبارها خط احمر
باعتبارها خطا احمر في حين ان الروس على
ما اعتقد كل ما يريدونه في في هذا الامر
هو النظام بصوره اساسيه هذه ن لكن اللافت
اللافت هنا سيد توفيق
شمان اللافت هنا ان طهران تبدي نوع من
الحذر والتشكيك سيد محمد قواص في اتفاق
وقف اطلاق النار يعني لا نقول بانها
تعارضه ولكن بعض وسائل الاعلام وبعض
الشخصيات النافذه خاصه في الحرس الثوري
تبدي شكوك وتحفظات حول مدى قدره هذا
الاتفاق على الصمود اذا برايك لماذا وفد
النظام ذهب لمن يشكك في وقف اطلاق النار
وليس لمن يرعاه او يدعمه مثل موسكو على
سبيل
المثال منطقيا الزياره هي رساله وطبعا
تواكبت هذه الرساله
بهجوم معلن وشاركت فيه طبعا ميليشيات حزب
الله بالاضافه الىى النظام في وادي برده
اضافه الى خروقات اخرى ادت الى تهديد
الجيش الحر بالانسحاب من هذا الاتفاق
اضافه الى ذلك وليس صدفه ان يصدر تصريح عن
الحرس او الناطق باسم الحرس الثوري يتحدث
عن ان الضامن هذه المره هي قوه النظام هذا
الاتفاق يعتمد على ان الضامن في هذا
الاتفاق هو طرفين موسكو و قره اليوم ايران
تتحدث عن ان الضامن لهذا الاتفاق هو قوه
النظام ثانيا تتحدث عن المبدا الاساسي
للصراع هو محاربه الارهاب علما ان
المجموعات التي شاركت في صياغه هذا
الاتفاق معتبره من قبل النظام ومن قبل ط
طهران مجموعات الارهابيه رغم تغير الموقف
الروسي اليوم الزياره تعتبر نكسه كبرى
لهذا الاتفاق وتعتبر رساله موجهه الى
موسكو مباشره لا نعرف حتى اليوم كيف سيكون
كيف كان الرد علما انه عرفنا ان هناك
اتصال جرى بين الرئيسين الايراني والروسي
في هذا الصدد لكن ايضا ا يعب تعبر هذه
الزياره لا نعرف اذا كانت الزياره زياره
سوريه ام انها استدع استدعاء ايراني عن
حاله قلق شديده تتشارك بها دمشق وطهران لم
الات هذا الاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار الذي
يفقد النظام قوته وفوقي الميدانيه بما
يتداعى بعد ذلك عن ما سيجري في اشتان نعم
اذا في هذه الحاله هناك نوع من التباينات
المحتمله في تفسير اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
في سوريا بين الجانب الايراني السوري من
ناحيه والطرف الروسي الضامن لتنفيذه نريد
ان نعرف بعد الفاصل حدود هذه التبينات
المحتمله لنا
[موسيقى]
عوده
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد موقف ايران
والنظام السوري من اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
في سوريا واحتمالات التباين في هذا الموقف
مع موقف روسيا التي هي الضامن لهذا
الاتفاق سيد سعيد الحاج قبل قليل سيد
توفيق شوان اشار الى مستويين القرار
الميداني والتقدير السياسي فيما يتعلق
بالقرار الميداني واضح ان تركيا لديها
تحفظات على
بقاء ما تسميها بال الميليشيات الطائفيه
وتطالب ايران بان تسعى لاخراجها من سوريه
هل تركيا تعتقد بان معيار التزام طهران هو
هذه المي شيات وخاصه الان حزب الله في ريف
دمشق الان يتحرك بشكل لا علاقه له باتفاق
وقف اطلاق
النار نعم علينا اولا ان ننتبه الى ان هذا
الاتفاق ووقف اطلاق النار ان تم فهو مصلحه
تركيه خالصه من وجهه النظر التركيه يعطيها
تهدئه تخفيف للضغوط عليها يعطيها اريحيه
اكثر في عمليه درع الفرات وغيرها من
المصالح السياسيه مع روسيا وغيرها
وبالتالي هناك هواجز تركيا تتعلق بسلامه و
ضمان وتامين هذا الاتفاق التصريحات
التركيه تحديدا على لسان وزير الخارجيه
جويش اوغلو تضمنت مسؤوليه او تحميل
المسؤوليه بشكل مباشر او غير مباشره
لايران عندما تحدث عن ان هناك اطراف تسعى
لخرق هذا الاتفاق او افشال وعندما تحدث ان
على ايران دورا مهما في ضمان التزام
النظام بهذا الامر فهو تحديدا يتحدث عن ان
ايران ان تم اختراق هذا الاتفاق عن طريق
النظام فهي المسؤوله عنه سياسيا على الاقل
الزياره السوريه السياسيه الامنيه الى
طهران توضح ان هناك تنسيقا سياسيا على
مستوى الاستانه وايضا تنسيقا ميدانيا نحن
امام سيناريو شبيه جدا بما حصل في حلب
وبالتالي هناك ايضا ضغط تركي على ايران
لكن ميدانيا لا تستطيعه تركيا لم تكن
تستطيعه سابقا والان في ظل فرض وقف اطلاق
النار لا تملكه العلاقات المباشره فضل
طرفان منذ فتره طويله جدا الابقاء عليها
هادئه وان كان هناك خلاف وتضارب في
المصالح كان هناك حرب بالوكاله على الارض
السوريه الان ربما حتى حده هذا الخلاف قد
خفضت انخفضت كثيرا ولذلك اعتقد ان ترك
تحاول الضغط على ايران عن من البوابه
الروسيه بان روسيا هي الضامنه وهي تتزعم
محور الدول الداعمه للنظام السوري
وبالتالي عليها مسؤوليه ضبط السلوك
الايراني كما ان على ايران ضبط سلوك
النظام السوري ويبدو ان انقره هنا تحاول
اللعب ولو هامشيا على مستوى العلاقات
الروسيه الايرانيه الخلاف ما زال باعتقادي
على التفاصيل وفي الهوامش نحن نتحدث عن
خلافات نسبيه في المصالح او التفاصيل او
الاهداف التفصيليه ولا نتحدث ان المحور
الايراني الروسي السوري قد فض تماما واصبح
هناك محور روسي تركي عفوا ن نتحدث عن س
الرت موضوع
المحاور نعم طالما اشرت الى موضوع المحاور
معذره لوحظ في في اليومين الماضيين سييد
توفيق شمان عوده الى استعمال لفظ محور
الممانعه مره اخرى وهناك تصريحات لمسؤولين
ايرانيين تقول بان محور الممانعه لا احد
يستطيع ان يتحكم في تحركاته ميدانيه وان
فيلق القدس هدفه الرئيسي هو تحرير القدس
ولكن هناك تنظيمات ارهابيه تحول بيننا
وبين هذا الهدف هل هذا نوع من التمهيد من
قبل محور الممانعه حزب الله الميليشيات
التي معها الحرس الثوري لاراك الوضع
الميداني في سوريا رغم وجود اتفاق وقف
اطلاق
النار يعني يعني بدون شك يعني يعني اولا
انا اركز على على نقطتين اساسيتين الاولى
ما له علاقه بسؤالك المباشر يعني بدون شك
بان قاعده محور الممانعه او المقاومه
طهران زائد دمشق زائد حزب الله اللبناني
هذه مساله اعتقد بان الاطراف الثلاثه يعني
تكيفوا معها وبالتالي مقتنعون بها تماما
هذه نقطه ولكن نقطه اخرى انا اعتقد بان
هناك مجموعه هواجس ايرانيه بما له علاقه
ان كان ب عمليه وقف اطلاق النار او
بالمؤتمر المقبل باسيانا وهنا بيت القصيد
السياسي الذي يمكن ان اتكلم حوله النقطه
الاولى انه على سبيل المثال انه هذا العام
كان هناك اكثر من عمليه توقف اطلاق النار
لم تنجح هذا هاجس انه تنجح هذه العمليه
التي بدات في 2829 ام لا واعتقد بان اي
مراقب يمكن ان يتفق مع ترام في هذه النقطه
الهاجس المساله الثانيه هو ما يتعلق
بالسياسه الخارجيه التركيه هل فعلا هناك
استداره ام ان السياسه الخارجيه التركيه
تنتظر قدوم الرئيس المنتخب دونالد ترامب
لاعاده بلوره سياستها الجديده على قاعده
ان التباين بين الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
واداره الرئيس باراك اوباما يعني كانت في
ذروتها عندما اتهم قبل ايام على سبيل
المثال السيد اردوغان الولايات المتحده
بدعم الارهاب هذه نقطه ثانيه النقطه
الثالثه ايضا ما له علاقه الى اي حد يمكن
ان تضمن تركيا عمليه وقف اطلاق النار في
جنوب سوريا على سبيل المثال حيث تاثيرها
ضعيف وفي غوطه دمشق الشرقيه والغربيه ايضا
حيث تاثيرها ضعيف في حين انه يمكن لتركيا
ان يكون لها تاثيرا تاثير وفاعليه ايضا في
الشمال السوري حيث اصدقائها وحلفائها من
المعارضات السوريه المختلفه موجوده في
الشمال السوري هذه نقاط ثلاث اساسيه اعتقد
تشكل هاجسا لاي مراقب وعلى قاعده التساؤل
العام هل تنجع عمليه وقف اطلاق الن نار ام
لا المساله الاخرى ايضا انه الى اي حد
يمكن على سبيل المثال وهذه النقطه الاخيره
ولن اطيل يمكن ان تضغط تركيا او تعيد
تاهيل جبهه النصره يعني اول امس على سبيل
المثال هناك معلومات تقول بان الاتراك
طلبوا من جبهه النصره او قد يطلبون اخراج
المقاتلين او المسلحين الاجانب واعاده
تاهيلها على قاعده الاسلام الوطني السوري
نعم يعني انت اشرت الى مجمل هذه الهواجس
او نقطه تباين بين طهران وبين نعم اشرت
الى مجمل هذه الهواجس الايرانيه ولكن هاجس
ربما روسيا الرئيسي سيد محمد قواص هو انها
لا تريد لهذا الاتفاق ان يفشل كل
المراقبين تقريبا يقولون ال ال الكاسب
الاول والابرز والمنتصر الرئيسي لا النظام
ولا المعارضه ولا تركيا كاسب رئيسي هو هي
روسيا وسياسه روسيا في المنطقه هل يمكن
لموسكو
ولبوته للنظام او لايران باربا ك هذا
الاتفاق وبعثرت اوراقه بعد ان حقق هذا
المكسب
الهام طبعا ايران تعرف جيدا ان روسيا
مستفيده جدا من هذا الاتفاق وتريد ان تطل
على العالم من خلال نجاحها بين مزدوجين في
الميدان السوري لذلك تحاول ايران من الان
حتى التنصيب الرسمي لدونالد ترامب وبعد
ذلك ايضا يعني وضوح سيا خارجيه للرئيس
الامريكي الجديد ان تحاول تحسين شروط هذه
الشراكه الجديده في استانه انا اتفهم طبعا
ما سمعت عن هواجس ايرانيه لكن الهواجس
الايرانيه هي هواجس محتمله انما الاخطار
الايرانيه هي اخطار انيه الهجمات التي
تحصل حاليا في وادي برده او في مناطق اخرى
والتي تهدد كل هذا الاتفاق هي اساسا اتيه
من مصدر واحد اما النظام ان المليشيات
التابعه لايران وبالتالي لا ما كان الان
الحديث عن هواجس اعتقد ايضا ان روسيا لا
تستطيع ان تفرض على ايران خياراتها لكنها
تستطيع ان تستغل ان ايران في موضع حرج جدا
اولا هي عليها ان تواجه اداره عدائيه من
الولايات المتحده مستقبلا والاتفاق النووي
مهدد وهي بحاجه الى هذه التغطيه الروسيه
والتغطيه الاقليميه بالشراكه مع تركيا
فايضا الوضع الايراني محرج نوعا ما لا
يستطيعون رفض ذلك هم يريدون ان يناور ان
يتلاعبوا في الدقائق الاخيره من هذا
الاتفاق
قبل موسكو الى اي مدى سيد قواس موسكو يمكن
ان ان ان تسمح بذلك الى الى فتره
طويله تستطيع ان تسمح بذلك طالما هي
لديها القرار الايراني الرسمي حاليا يعني
لاحظ اننا بايران لا نفهم من يحكم هل هو
الرئيس روحاني هل هو وزير الخارجيه اي
الذي يمثل الدبلوماسيه امهم الحرس الثوري
ام ام ام المرشد روسيا ايضا تريد ان تعرف
كيف هو القرار الايراني وهي تستغل ايضا
وضع ايران وضع محرج جدا وهي تعرف اكثر
روسيا ان ايران تعلم ان كل جهود العسكريه
سواء من خلال النظام السوري او من خلال
الميليشيات ليست هي من اسقط حلب وان
العامل الرئيسي في تقويه هذا النظام في
سوريا هو العامل الروسي واذا ما انسحب هذا
العامل الروسي كما لمح بوتين بعد الاتفاق
بتخفيف الوجود العسكري فان كل المناوره
الايرانيه تصبح مناوره تخريبيه وليست جزء
من شراكه بامكانها ان تقدمها وتعيد
تاهيلها من جديد الى المجتمع الدولي شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد محمد قواص الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي من باريس شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
بيروت توفيق شمان الكاتب الصحفي ومن
اسطنبول سعيد الحاج الباحث في الشان
التركي بهذا مشاهدينا الرام نكون قد وصلنا
الى نهايه هذه الحلقه نتمنى لكم عاما
جديدا سعيدا دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء